what we're going to do in this video is
think about different ways to represent
multiplication and especially connect it
to the notions of skip counting and the
number line
so if we were to think about what 4
times
2 means we've already seen in other
videos you could view this as four
groups of two so we could have four
groups so one group
two groups
three groups and four groups and each of
them have two of something i'll just put
two little circles here so you have 2
there you have 2 there you have 2 there
and you have 2 there and you could also
view that as 4 2s or 4 2s added together
so we could view it as two
plus two plus two plus two
and this of course is going to be two
plus two is four four plus two is six
six plus two is eight we see that over
here we could even skip count two four 6
8 4 times 2 is equal to 8. we can also
think about that on a number line
so i'm going to make a little bit of a
number line here
and so we can imagine 4 times 2 being
all right
so this is one times two
two times two
three times two and four times two so we
started at zero and we took four hops of
two along the number line to end up at
eight
we went from zero to two four six eight
we just counted our way to eight
so if i were to ask a similar question
actually let me draw a little a series
of hops and i want you to think about it
the other way what what multiplication
does that represent
so let's say i start here
and then i'm going to hop like this so
i'm going to go there
and then i'm going to go there i'm
taking equal jumps every time then i'm
going to go there
then i'm going to go
there
and then i'm going to go
over there
so what would that represent if we use
the same type of ideas that we just
thought about
well i went from 0 to 4 8 12 16 20. i'm
skip counting by 4. so you can imagine
this is probably something times four
now how many hops did i take i took one
two three four five hops of four so this
is five times four
and we can see that we ended up
at twenty we could also view this as
being the same thing as five fours or
four plus four plus four plus four plus
four and you see that over here you have
we're starting at zero we're adding four
then another four then another four then
another four and another four we have
five fours here
let's do one more
so i'm gonna have a number line here and
think about what it would mean to say do
something like
7
times
three
times
three
well we could view that as seven hops of
three starting at zero seven equal hops
so
one
two
three
four
five
six
and
seven we end up at 21 so this is equal
to
21. you could also view this as we took
seven threes and added them together we
got and you could also view the skip
counting you went from zero to three six
nine twelve fifteen eighteen and twenty
one
now just out of interest what if we went
the other way around what if we were to
take three hops of seven what would that
be
well we would start here and so we would
take our first top of
seven right over there we get to seven
then if we take another hop of seven we
get to fourteen and then if we take
another hop of 7 we get 2
21. interesting at least for this
situation whether we took 7 hops of 3 or
3 hops of 7 we got to the exact same
value i encourage you to think about
whether that's always going to be the
case
i'll see you in a future video